Hello listener. Welcome to Smart List. This is a podcast that is basically it's a little chat show. And there's there's three dumb dudes asking dumb questions to a slightly smarter guest. And this guest is a mystery to two of the question askers. I've never brought this up before, but your tone sounds like an information video, like at a funeral home. Well, I'm just trying to get on with it, you know, this is what you can expect in the funeral process. I don't even know why we're still doing explanations of what the podcast is. People know what they're
你好，听众朋友们。欢迎收听《Smart List》。这基本上是一个小型聊天节目。有三个笨蛋在向一位稍微聪明点的嘉宾问些愚蠢的问题。对于其中两个提问者来说，这位嘉宾是个谜。我以前从没提过，但你的语调听起来像是一段宣传视频，就像殡仪馆里的那种。好吧，我只是想继续进行下去，你知道，这就是你在葬礼流程中可以预期的内容。我甚至不知道为什么我们还在解释这个播客是什么。人们知道他们正在
tuning into. Just ask them to listen like a like a credit sequence of a show. Like they get it. They know where they're at. Get on with the story. Yeah. Right. Yeah. Just let's just start the episode. All right. It's all new. Smart List. Yeah. Jason, are you sleepy today?
收听什么。就像节目的片尾字幕一样，让他们听就行了。他们懂的。他们知道自己在哪里。继续讲故事吧。是啊。对。我们就直接开始这一集吧。好的。全新的《Smart List》。是啊。Jason，你今天困吗？
Yeah. No, I'm just... What happened, Angel? You know what I've realized? I'm 51 years old. I think I'm moody. I think I've realized it's taken... I mean, you guys have known me for a while. Am I a little late to this realization? It must have gone to your junk box because you're the last to get the memo. Yeah. I'm a real squeaky wheel for no reason. We know.
是啊。不，我只是……怎么了，Angel？你知道我意识到什么了吗？我51岁了。我想我情绪化了。我想我意识到这花了我……我的意思是，你们认识我也有一段时间了。我对这个认识是不是有点晚了？那一定是被扔进你的垃圾箱了，因为你是最后一个收到消息的人。是啊。我无缘无故地成了一个爱抱怨的人。我们知道。
There's absolutely no reason for me to be in a bad mood today. Sometimes he's a real grumper. What is... I say this with all respect to those who seriously suffer from it, but what is the definition of bipolar? I just want to know if I can self-diagnose. I think your high is a real high and your low is a real low. And you become manic. Right. Can you self-diagnose or do you have to ask friends that you're close to? You just asked me. Yeah. So what's your opinion? Do I qualify for that?
我今天绝对没有理由心情不好。有时候他确实是个老顽固。什么是……我怀着对那些真正受此困扰的人的全部敬意说这句话，但双相情感障碍的定义是什么？我只是想知道我能不能自我诊断。我想你的高潮是真的高，低谷也是真的低。然后你就变得狂躁了。对。你可以自我诊断，还是必须问问你亲近的朋友？你刚才问我了。是啊。那你觉得呢？我符合那个标准吗？
Let's take... Watch you take a sip of that. Okay. So that's just plain water, right? Or is that... You have it. You have it. By the way, I mean, I think everybody's been feeling level. And again, not to, not to diminish people have this clinically, but depression. I think that there have been levels. I think that there are levels of it. And people have been experiencing it. I certainly... I started going on Prozac right before this podcast. The pandemic.
让我们……看着你喝一口那个。好吧，那是纯水，对吧？还是……你喝吧。你喝吧。顺便说一句，我的意思是，我觉得每个人都感觉很平稳。再说一次，不是要贬低那些临床上有这种情况的人，而是抑郁症。我认为它是有程度之分的。我认为它有不同的级别。人们一直在经历它。我当然……我在这个播客之前就开始服用百忧解了。疫情期间。
Oh. Right before lunch. Right before lunch today. Wait. Before the pandemic, did you sense there was a disturbance in the force and you thought... No, I did not. I had disturbance. And you were like, a better pill up because something wicked this way comes? No, no. We'll talk about that later. But yeah, no, I should have been taking it 20 years ago, but it's... I started my happy pill 20 years ago. I'm a big, big advocate of...
哦。午饭前。今天午饭前。等等。在疫情之前，你感觉到原力中有某种扰动，然后你觉得……不，我没有。我有扰动。然后你就想，最好吃颗药，因为邪恶的东西要来了？不，不。我们以后再谈那个。但是的，不，我20年前就应该开始服用了，但……我20年前就开始服用我的快乐药丸了。我是……的坚定拥护者。
Yeah. So I... But it's beneficial that I'm taking it now that we've... We're in this. I'm surprised that it took you this long to... Because I find your life depressing. So you know what I mean? Is he talking to me or is he talking to you, Sean? I'm talking to both of you. You took both of us. Okay. Okay. So guys, as I introduce this guy, you
是啊。所以我……但现在我们……我们处于这种状态，我服用它是有益的。我很惊讶你花了这么长时间才……因为我觉得你的生活很压抑。所以你知道我的意思吗？他是在跟我说话还是在跟你说话，Sean？我是在跟你们俩说话。你把我们俩都带上了。好吧。好吧。那么伙计们，当我介绍这位伙计的时候，你们
guys are going to know who he is right off the bat. So this fella, whom I'm a huge fan of, he grew up in the South Charleston, North Carolina. And it's an unbelievably incredible singer-songwriter. He formed his now famous band back in 86 about... And about a decade later, won a couple of Grammys, sold over 25 million records. The name of the band, this is how you're going to get it, is Hootie and the Blowfish. We got it. The name of the superstar is Darius Rucker. What?
马上就会知道他是谁。所以这位我非常崇拜的家伙，他在南卡罗来纳州的南查尔斯顿长大。他是一位令人难以置信的杰出创作歌手。他在86年左右组建了他现在著名的乐队……大约十年后，赢得了几项格莱美奖，唱片销量超过2500万张。乐队的名字，这就是你们会猜到的方式，是Hootie and the Blowfish。我们猜到了。这位超级巨星的名字是Darius Rucker。什么？
Darius Rucker. I said it before you. Hello. No way. Hi, Darius. Hello. And he's holding a mic like a rock star should. Absolutely, I am. Absolutely.
Darius Rucker。我比你先说出来的。你好。不会吧。嗨，Darius。你好。而且他拿着麦克风的样子就像摇滚明星应该有的样子。绝对是，我就是。绝对是。
Perfect. Because I couldn't pack my mic stand in my bag. So I got to hold it. And now, is that a... What do you call it? Euphemism? No? No. It's not. Because I've heard Will say that before and I never knew what he was talking about. That was euphemism.
完美。因为我没法把麦克风支架塞进包里。所以我得拿着它。现在，那是一个……你叫它什么？委婉语？不？不。不是。因为我以前听Will说过，我从来不知道他在说什么。那是委婉语。
Oh. Wow. Darius, your name actually sounds Southern. It sounds like Matthew McConaughey would have a blast with your name. Oh, yeah. I like what he says. Hey, hey Darius. I like what he says. He's so relaxed all the time. He is so relaxed. When I was younger, you know, which is not recent.
哦。哇。Darius，你的名字听起来确实很有南方味。听起来Matthew McConaughey会很喜欢你的名字。哦，是的。我喜欢他说的话。嘿，嘿Darius。我喜欢他说的话。他一直都很放松。他确实很放松。我年轻的时候，你知道，那不是最近的事了。
Sean's having a tough time remembering because it was so long ago, that's why it's taking me away. Check your notes. I'm dead serious. I would be in my car listening to your songs. I bought all your CDs. And I would try so hard to sound like you when I sang. Because your voice is one of the best coolest voices I've ever heard. I agree. And it's so identifiable. And did you always sing like that? Like, when did you open your
Sean很难回忆起来，因为那是很久以前的事了，这就是为什么我走神了。查查你的笔记。我是认真的。我以前在车里听你的歌。我买了你所有的CD。我唱歌的时候会非常努力地模仿你的声音。因为你的声音是我听过的最好、最酷的声音之一。我同意。而且非常有辨识度。你一直都是那样唱歌吗？就像，你什么时候张开
mouth and realize, hey, I think I have a pretty cool voice? Oh, thank you for saying that. Everybody does the, we wanna be with you. Everybody does that. I think they sound just like me. Exactly. Exactly. I like to think, Darius, that your singing career began just one day you were driving and out of the blue you went, I don't wanna be with you. I gotta start a band. I gotta
嘴，意识到，嘿，我觉得我的声音挺酷的？哦，谢谢你这么说。每个人都做那个，我们想和你在一起。每个人都那样做。我想他们听起来就像我一样。完全正确。完全正确。Darius，我喜欢认为你的歌唱生涯开始于有一天你开车时，突然冒出一句，我不想和你在一起。我得组建一个乐队。我得
start a band. Actually. It's a day. It's all I wanted to do since I was four. When I was a four year old, I discovered Al Green and he was big for me. I thought he was a genius. Yeah. So did you sign him right there? Yeah, I would have.
组建一个乐队。其实。那是某一天。从我四岁起，这就是我唯一想做的事。当我四岁的时候，我发现了Al Green，他对我影响很大。我觉得他是个天才。是啊。那你当时就签下他了吗？是啊，我会的。
I mean, you just listen to him. You just listen to him. I got it. I didn't discover him. Okay. And it was great for me. And ever since I was a kid, this is all I ever wanted to do. I'm really surprised. I was talking to a friend last night about it and it's just shocking that, you know, I'm 54 years old. I'm still getting to do it this level. It's pretty crazy. Yeah. Darius. So with the advantage of hindsight now and all the sort of accrued data over the last, I don't know, 20, 30 years and maybe that's, it's been that long since iTunes
我的意思是，你只要听他的歌就行了。我明白了。我没有发现他。好吧。这对我很棒。从我还是个孩子的时候起，这就是我唯一想做的事。我真的很惊讶。我昨晚和一个朋友谈起这件事，令人震惊的是，你知道，我54岁了。我还能在这个水平上做这件事。这太疯狂了。是啊。Darius。那么现在有了事后诸葛亮的优势，以及过去，我不知道，20、30年里积累的所有数据，也许从iTunes
sort of changed the music industry into what it is today as far as brick and mortar stores going away. What is the section of people in the industry that have benefited from that versus those that are at a disadvantage now? Or is it good for everyone across the industry now that they've had a chance to kind of find some equality with some of the, some of the parts of it? It's good for the consumer. It's great for the consumer because music is so easy to get now. I mean, when we were younger, we had to go stand and we'll line up the record store on Tuesday to buy the new record. You know, now you just get it on your phone or get it
把音乐产业变成今天的样子，实体店消失了，已经过去那么久了。在行业中，哪些人从中受益，而哪些人现在处于劣势？或者说，现在整个行业的人都有机会在某些部分找到某种平等，这对每个人都有好处吗？这对消费者来说是好事。这对消费者来说太棒了，因为现在获取音乐太容易了。我的意思是，当我们年轻的时候，我们必须在周二去唱片店排队买新唱片。你知道，现在你只要在手机上或者在
wherever. That's been great. The people who started those businesses, it's been great. Yeah. And even the record companies, you know, it's been great, but the laws haven't caught up for the artist yet. Like, you know, the CEO of Spotify walks away with billions of dollars and we're making 0.0001 cent every time they play my song. Right. So tell me, do you feel like some of the magic has gone because there isn't that anticipation of waiting? Like you were saying, waiting to, I remember the first record that I went and bought on my own. I was 11. It was 1981. And I took the subway downtown Toronto
任何地方就能得到它。那太棒了。那些创办这些企业的人，这太棒了。是啊。甚至唱片公司，你知道，这也很棒，但法律还没有为艺术家赶上。就像，你知道，Spotify的首席执行官带着数十亿美元离开，而我们每次播放我的歌只赚0.0001美分。对。所以告诉我，你觉得因为没有那种等待的期待感，魔力消失了吗？就像你说的，等待，我记得我第一次自己去买的唱片。我11岁。那是1981年。我坐地铁去多伦多市中心
to buy. The Donna Summer album. The Donna Summer album. Donna Summer, Carthar Park. No, no, to buy, to buy ACDC Dirty Deeds Thunder cheap. Yeah. That was the first record I bought. I instantly regretted it. But is some of the magic gone in that process? Oh, yeah. I think that feeling of waiting for that record and getting it and opening it up and reading the liner notes and, you know, looking at the pictures or whatever, that's gone. And the thing, even for artists, you're like, there's artists now, like I still
去买。Donna Summer的专辑。Donna Summer的专辑。Donna Summer，Carthar Park。不，不，去买，去买ACDC的《Dirty Deeds Done Dirt Cheap》。是啊。那是我买的第一张唱片。我立刻就后悔了。但那个过程中是不是失去了一些魔力？哦，是的。我认为那种等待那张唱片，得到它，打开它，阅读内页说明，你知道，看照片什么的，那种感觉已经消失了。而且，即使对艺术家来说，你就像，现在有艺术家，比如我仍然
make records. Like I still, I still make albums and I want people to listen to back and forth. People are just out there making singles now. They don't, it doesn't matter. That whole process doesn't matter. Is it true that you have to kind of play this game of releasing the music, knowing you're not going to get a kind of monetary reward from it because the way to make a living now is just touring and touring only. This is the perfect explanation of pre digital is, uh, when we were doing our thing, the only reason we went on tour, like the only reason we went out and paid shows was to make
制作唱片。比如我仍然，我仍然制作专辑，我希望人们从头到尾听。人们现在只是在外面制作单曲。他们不，这不重要。整个过程都不重要。是不是真的，你必须玩这种发行音乐的游戏，因为你知道你不会从中得到任何金钱回报，因为现在谋生的方式只是巡演，而且只有巡演。这是对前数字时代的完美解释，呃，当我们做我们的事情时，我们去巡演的唯一原因，就像我们出去表演的唯一原因就是为了让
people buy our records. That's the only reason you went on tour was, I mean, you were making money touring, but you're making so much money selling records. You just out there trying to get people to go buy your records. And now today, the only reason you make a record is so you can tour every year. Right. Amazing. I mean, it's the exact opposite. So basically a hundred percent of the, well, 90% of the income from the band is ticket
人们买我们的唱片。你巡演的唯一原因就是，我的意思是，你巡演能赚钱，但你卖唱片赚的钱太多了。你只是在外面试图让人们去买你的唱片。而今天，你制作唱片的唯一原因就是为了让你每年都能巡演。对。太神奇了。我的意思是，这完全相反。所以基本上乐队100%的，好吧，90%的收入来自门票
sales and concessions and souvenirs shirts. Yeah. Then has your percentage of the gate and the souvenirs and stuff like that, has that gone up or has it stayed the same? You know, it's going up just cause you know, my, my standing in the music business is going up, but you know, the basic things are still the same as they were. So that's a negotiation point as far as percentage of ticket sales and concessions and stuff like that. Absolutely.
销售、特许经营和纪念品衬衫。是啊。那么你从门票和纪念品之类的收入比例有没有提高，还是保持不变？你知道，它在提高，只是因为你知道，我在音乐界的地位在提高，但你知道，基本的东西和以前一样。所以就门票销售和特许经营之类的百分比而言，这是一个谈判点。绝对是。
It wasn't something that was put on the table as a negotiation point as sort of a make good since record sales went away for artists. The venues and whatnot didn't say, okay, so now you can have some of the gate. It's just, it's always been the same and the more juice you have in the industry, the bigger percentage you get. Exactly. Live nation, they ain't looking to hook nobody up. They're looking to make money. Right. They're not, they don't feel bad for you. Right. Madison Square Garden is like, how
这并不是作为一个谈判点放在桌面上，作为唱片销售消失后对艺术家的一种补偿。场馆之类的并没有说，好吧，现在你可以分一些门票收入了。它一直都是一样的，你在行业里的影响力越大，你得到的百分比就越高。完全正确。Live Nation，他们不想给任何人好处。他们想赚钱。对。他们不，他们不为你感到难过。对。麦迪逊广场花园就像，你
dare you, you know what? You guys haven't sold that many records. So yeah, we're going to give you 80% of the gate. Pat you on the head. Yeah. Yeah. But it must be, isn't that funny the way that that flipped? When, when was that moment? Do you remember like a year when the sales kind of went that way and became touring? When Apple music came about, when iTunes started and people could get it on the phone and you know, and at that point, and when, you know, Napster started and they didn't try to buy
怎么敢，你知道吗？你们卖的唱片没那么多。所以是的，我们要给你80%的门票收入。拍拍你的头。是啊。是啊。但这一定，那种翻转的方式不是很滑稽吗？那个时刻是什么时候？你还记得唱片销售变成巡演的那一年吗？当Apple Music出现时，当iTunes开始时，人们可以在手机上得到它，你知道，在那一点上，当，你知道，Napster开始时，他们没有试图买
it. They tried to, they tried to crush it. If the record labels had gotten together and bought it, they would own it. You know, they had that, they would own the technology and that was really where it all changed. Wasn't, I'm assuming that there is a union for these, for, for artists that could have and perhaps now in hindsight should have said, hang on a second, Apple, worse, you're not allowed to do that. We have an infrastructure and a way in which to monetize album sales and whatnot. You can't come in and now turn it into an all a cart business and just relegate any income for bands to touring and merchandising and stuff like that. We say no as a union.
它。他们试图，他们试图摧毁它。如果唱片公司联合起来买下它，他们就会拥有它。你知道，他们有那个，他们会拥有这项技术，而那确实是这一切改变的地方。不是，我假设有一个针对这些，针对艺术家的工会，本可以，也许现在事后看来应该说，等一下，Apple，更糟的是，你们不允许那样做。我们有一个基础设施和一种货币化专辑销售之类的方式。你们不能进来，现在把它变成一个点菜式的业务，仅仅把乐队的任何收入降级为巡演和商品销售之类的。我们作为工会说不。
We tried, but the, it was such a new technology and you know, it wasn't even, there weren't even laws. There was no laws governing what was happening. And was it somehow spun as well? Don't worry about it. It's going to be beneficial. There's still going to be Tower Records, but this is going to be on top of it. And we're going to figure it out. Exactly. It's going to be more exposure. Exactly. You know, we'll figure out the money. When people are listening to your music, it's good for you guys. You know, but it's a great thing. I mean, I'm at that point when I'm not mad at anybody
我们试过了，但那是一项太新的技术，你知道，甚至没有，甚至没有法律。没有任何法律来管理正在发生的事情。而且它是否也被某种程度上美化了？别担心。这会有益的。仍然会有Tower Records，但这将是它的补充。我们会弄明白的。完全正确。这会有更多的曝光率。完全正确。你知道，我们会弄明白钱的问题。当人们在听你们的音乐时，这对你们有好处。你知道，但这是一件好事。我的意思是，我处于那个阶段，我没有对任何人感到愤怒
or mad about it. It is what it is and you got to do what you got to do with it. I still did this day feel guilty when I'm like, you know, my daughter's in the car and I say, you know, what was it the other day we were talking about? I know she's 13. She's discovering like, dad, have you ever heard this song by the psychedelic furs? Am I saying that word right? And I said, yeah. And as you started, I said, have you ever heard English beat? And like, so I start pulling up England and I don't, I don't own the English beat, an English beat album, but I just could for free just hit the search bar and boom, up comes every song that they've ever recorded. And I'm just playing it in my car for no money
或对此感到愤怒。事实就是这样，你必须用它做你必须做的事。我直到今天仍然感到内疚，当我像，你知道，我女儿在车里，我说，你知道，前几天我们在谈论什么？我知道她13岁了。她正在发现，比如，爸爸，你听过Psychedelic Furs的这首歌吗？我那个词说对了吗？我说，是的。当你开始的时候，我说，你听过English Beat吗？然后，所以我开始调出England，我没有，我不拥有English Beat，一张English Beat专辑，但我只是可以免费点击搜索栏，砰，他们录制过的每一首歌都出来了。我只是在车里播放它，没有任何钱
at all, except for this fee that I pay each month, you know, that is just on automatic delivery. Yeah. And it's, it doesn't seem, it doesn't seem fair to you guys. I mean, I get what you're saying. And because it doesn't seem fair to us to either, you know, when we see it, but it's just the way it's just a week is nothing we can do about, you know, let we had a, we passed, they passed the law last year that, that helped a little bit. It just, it was, it still wasn't really it's just, it's just the way it is. And sometimes you'll never change, which reminds me, I've just brought Bruce Winsby's record this morning. I paid for the whole thing.
，除了我每个月支付的这笔费用，你知道，那只是自动交付的。是啊。而且，这看起来，这对你们来说似乎不公平。我的意思是，我明白你在说什么。而且因为这对我们来说也不公平，你知道，当我们看到它时，但这只是方式，只是一个星期，我们对此无能为力，你知道，让我们有一个，我们通过了，他们去年通过了一项法律，这有一点帮助。它只是，它仍然不是真的，它只是，它就是这样。而且有时候你永远不会改变，这让我想起，我今天早上刚买了Bruce Winsby的唱片。我付了全款。
I love it. If you just lifted up a keyboard, just right, right now, I would have, I would have been in heaven. So Darius, I'm going to switch gears for a second here because I'm so glad you're on, what's that? What the clutch? So hang, everybody hang on tight. You know, I'm so glad you're here today because being black in America right now and is rightfully so like a global conversation that everybody's having and I'm anxious to get your take on a question. I'm sure you're so tired of, which is what has it been like and what is it like now being black in the country music scene since you started and did you experience any racism, inequality, anything like that
我喜欢它。如果你现在抬起键盘，就在现在，我就会在天堂了。所以Darius，我要在这里换个话题，因为我很高兴你来了，那是什么？什么离合器？所以等等，大家抓紧了。你知道，我很高兴你今天在这里，因为作为美国的黑人，现在，理所当然地，这是一个每个人都在进行的全球对话，我很渴望得到你对一个问题的看法。我相信你已经厌倦了，那就是，自从你开始以来，作为乡村音乐界的黑人是什么感觉，现在是什么感觉，你经历过任何种族主义、不平等，任何类似的事情吗
back then versus now? And what, what has been your overall experience with that? Yeah, overall, it's been great. When I first started 14 years ago, 14 years ago, we did a radio tour where we, I went to 110 radio stations and it was shocking to me because a few, I had a few, a few guys and I will say right now, these guys are some of my biggest supporters right now, but I had guys sit me down and tell me that I love the song. I think it's country. I'm going to try to play it, but I don't think it's going to work because I don't think my audience will ever accept the black countries. Wow.
那时和现在相比？你对此的总体体验是什么？是啊，总的来说，这很棒。14年前我刚开始的时候，14年前，我们做了一次电台巡演，我去过110个电台，这让我感到震惊，因为有几个，我有几个，几个家伙，我现在要说，这些家伙现在是我最大的支持者，但我有家伙让我坐下来告诉我，我喜欢这首歌。我觉得它是乡村音乐。我会试着播放它，但我不认为它会成功，因为我不认为我的听众会接受黑人乡村音乐。哇。
It's like that to me. Oh yeah, straight up, you know, they won't accept it and they don't even, they're just listening to it on the radio. Yeah. And they won't accept the notion of it. Yeah. And that's what he said, you know, and few guys said that. And, you know, and when it went number one, you know, they all called me and said, we were wrong. Right. But yeah, that was the mentality of the business at the time that it just, there wasn't room for a black singer and country music. Everybody wants to be the second person to say, yes. Exactly. And then, you know, but once it hit and, you know, now we got King Brown and Timmy Allen and Mickey Guyton and all these, these kids out here having hits and country music
对我来说就是那样。哦，是的，直接说，你知道，他们不会接受它，他们甚至没有，他们只是在收音机里听它。是啊。他们甚至不会接受它的概念。是啊。这就是他说的，你知道，几个人这么说了。而且，你知道，当它成为第一名时，你知道，他们都打电话给我说，我们错了。对。但是的，那是当时商业的心态，就是没有黑人歌手在乡村音乐中的空间。每个人都想成为第二个说，是的的人。完全正确。然后，你知道，但一旦它火了，你知道，现在我们有King Brown和Timmy Allen和Mickey Guyton，所有这些在这里有热门歌曲的孩子，乡村音乐
that are black. And, you know, I look at it, it's just changing. Somebody asked me early on if I thought I'd changed country music when I started having hits. And I just said, I just hope some kid who had a CD that would actually get listened to instead of getting thrown in the trash because they had a black face on it, you know, and it's great to see people having big hits. That's wild. Yeah. It was crazy. This is a super cool fact that I learned when I was reading about it. We'll see. We'll see. We'll see. When, when Darius Rucker first went solo with your first single in 2008, it made it to the top 20 on the Billboard charts, making you the first African-American singer to reach the top of the country charts
是黑人。而且，你知道，我看着它，它正在改变。有人早些时候问我，当我开始有热门歌曲时，我是否认为我改变了乡村音乐。我只是说，我只是希望某个孩子有一张CD，它会被真正听到，而不是因为上面有一张黑人脸而被扔进垃圾桶，你知道，看到人们有热门歌曲真是太棒了。那太疯狂了。是啊。这太疯狂了。这是我读到它时学到的一个超级酷的事实。我们会看到的。我们会看到的。我们会看到的。当，当Darius Rucker在2008年凭借你的第一首单曲首次单飞时，它进入了Billboard排行榜的前20名，使你成为第一位达到乡村排行榜顶峰的非裔美国歌手
in like 20 years. Yeah. 25 years. Yeah. It was Charlie Pratt. I didn't even think about that going into it. And when it hit the top 25, somebody came and said that to me. You know, I had named three or four, like Trini Triggs and these other guys that were black country singers in the 80s and 90s. I thought might have had a hit or Cowboy Troy today. And, and it was crazy to me that 25 years between me and Charlie Pratt having hits on country radio. Did you see yourself as, as a sort of a trailblazer? Was that ever a notion that you had or no, you just wanted to make music. And that was, and when people told you though, you're like, Oh, you were shocked. When I started with Hootie, I wanted to play
在25年里。是啊。25年。是啊。那是Charlie Pratt。我进入它时甚至没想过那个。当它进入前25名时，有人过来对我说了那个。你知道，我曾列举了三四个，比如Trini Triggs和这些在80年代和90年代的其他黑人乡村歌手。我以为可能有一首热门歌曲，或者今天的Cowboy Troy。而且，我和Charlie Pratt在乡村电台有热门歌曲之间相隔25年，这对我来说太疯狂了。你是否把自己看作是某种开拓者？那是一个你曾经有过的概念吗，还是不，你只是想做音乐。而且那是，当人们告诉你时，你就像，哦，你很震惊。我和Hootie开始时，我想玩
rock and roll because I want to play rock and roll with those guys. You know, and then when I, when I wanted to sing country, I was going to make the, my record in my basement studio with my buddies, you know, drinking beer and make a country record. And my man, I managed by Doc McGee at the time and Doc doesn't, didn't see things that way and got me a record deal. But you made the transition from rock and roll to country. Yeah. That desire to play cut. Was that always in you? Like as you were, you guys were the biggest band in the world, but where you were like, I'm really not doing what I totally want to do. Cause you were at the top top. Yeah. I used to ask the guys to play country music.
摇滚乐，因为我想和那些家伙一起玩摇滚乐。你知道，然后当我，当我想要唱乡村音乐时，我打算和我的哥们在我的地下室工作室里制作我的唱片，你知道，喝啤酒，制作一张乡村唱片。而我的伙计，我当时由Doc McGee管理，Doc没有，没有那样看事情，并为我争取到了唱片合约。但你完成了从摇滚乐到乡村音乐的转变。是啊。那种想玩乡村音乐的渴望。那一直都在你心里吗？就像你，你们是世界上最伟大的乐队，但你在哪里就像，我真的没有做我完全想做的事。因为你在顶端。是啊。我过去常要求伙计们玩乡村音乐。
Like our last couple of records, I was like, let's just go to Nashville and make country record and they'd be like, man, we're a rock band. And so they wouldn't do it. I listened to country music growing up and then 1989, a guy named Radney Foster came out with a record called Del Rio, Texas, 1959. And it changed my life. I heard that record and thought someday I want to sound just like that guy. I got to make a country record and I'd say it all the time and they would laugh at me and finally I got a chance to do it. And the draw for country music for you is it, does it live mostly in the, in the sound of it and, and sort of the, the unique instrumentation of it? Or is it in this sort of the, the lyrics,
就像我们最后几张唱片，我说，我们去纳什维尔制作乡村唱片吧，他们会说，伙计，我们是摇滚乐队。所以他们不会做。我从小听乡村音乐，然后1989年，一个叫Radney Foster的家伙出了一张叫《Del Rio, Texas, 1959》的唱片。它改变了我的生活。我听了那张唱片，想有一天我想听起来就像那个家伙。我得制作一张乡村唱片，我一直这么说，他们会嘲笑我，最后我终于有机会做了。而乡村音乐对你的吸引力是，它主要存在于，在它的声音中，以及，某种程度上，它独特的乐器编排中？还是在于这种，歌词，
the stories that are, that are talked about, what grabs you most? The most is the storytelling. I love, I love how country tells the stories. But, you know, when you get to sing with a, with a real good slide guitar playing with you, man, or real good fiddle playing with you, man, yeah, I get chills thinking about it. Do you like sort of the hybrid sound of it, of a band like Wilco too? Yeah, I love them. You know, Wilco and the silos back in the day and, you know, a sun vote, you know, Sunvolt was huge for me. That first record. Wow. I was talking about Sunvolt and about Uncle Tupelo with both of those bands.
谈论的故事，什么最吸引你？最吸引我的是讲故事。我喜欢，我喜欢乡村音乐讲故事的方式。但是，你知道，当你能和一个，和一个真正好的滑棒吉他手一起唱歌，或者一个真正好的小提琴手和你一起演奏时，伙计，是啊，想到它我都会起鸡皮疙瘩。你喜欢像Wilco这样的乐队的混合声音吗？是啊，我喜欢他们。你知道，Wilco和The Silos在过去，而且，你知道，Sun Volt，你知道，Sun Volt对我影响很大。那第一张唱片。哇。我当时在谈论Sun Volt和Uncle Tupelo，关于那两个乐队。
Absolutely. Yeah. So good. Big for me. Big for me. Do you ever venture off and like, what would be the most surprising thing you could tell me that you listened to that to be like, what? Barry Manilow. Yes. I listened to Barry Manilow. Not surprised. He's not, he's not my guilty pleasure. He's awesome.
绝对是。是啊。太好了。对我影响很大。对我影响很大。你有没有冒险去，比如，你能告诉我的最令人惊讶的事情是什么，你听了之后会像，什么？Barry Manilow。是的。我听Barry Manilow。不惊讶。他不是，他不是我的罪恶快感。他太棒了。
He's awesome. He's awesome. All right. Who's your guilty pleasure then? I don't have one. I mean, I don't think that way. Everybody I love, I love, like, you know, Neil Diamond and Barry Manilow and, you know, I threw on a Dean Martin record the other day and, you know, Dean is just, I mean, I love that stuff. I love, I love everything, man. I love everything. How much are you missing touring right now? Do you miss being out there and playing for
他太棒了。他太棒了。好吧。那谁是你的罪恶快感？我没有。我的意思是，我不那样想。我爱的每个人，我都爱，比如，你知道，Neil Diamond和Barry Manilow，而且，你知道，前几天我放了一张Dean Martin的唱片，而且，你知道，Dean只是，我的意思是，我喜欢那些东西。我喜欢，我喜欢一切，伙计。我喜欢一切。你现在有多想念巡演？你怀念在外面为
people? I'll bet you do. Yeah. You know, when you take a week off or two weeks off or three weeks off, you always had that show on the calendar where you knew you were playing. You always said, we're going to play in Phoenix. I'm going to play whatever. And not knowing has shown me that I love to play music so much and I miss it so much, man. Are you coming up with songs you probably never would have or melodies you probably never would have because you're sitting there just staring at the walls for weeks and weeks.
人们表演吗？我敢打赌你怀念。是啊。你知道，当你休息一个星期，或者两个星期，或者三个星期时，你总是会在日历上有那个你知道你要表演的演出。你总是说，我们要去凤凰城表演。我要去表演什么。而不知道这一点让我意识到我非常喜欢演奏音乐，而且我非常想念它，伙计。你是不是想出了你可能永远不会有的歌曲，或者你可能永远不会有的旋律，因为你坐在那里只是盯着墙看了几个星期又几个星期。
Yeah. I've written some songs in this, this next record. I can't wait for people to hear this next record. I've written some crazy stuff. Do you remember the very first song you wrote? And then sing some of it. Goodness. A buddy of mine and I, he had written most of it and I think I wrote a few lines for it, but he wrote it. But I just remember the chorus was destiny, destiny. It's destiny. That was the whole chorus. Okay, good.
是啊。我在这张下一张唱片里写了一些歌。我迫不及待地想让人们听到这张下一张唱片。我写了一些疯狂的东西。你还记得你写的第一首歌吗？然后唱一点。天哪。我和一个哥们，他写了大部分，我想我为它写了几行，但他写了它。但我只记得副歌是命运，命运。这是命运。那是整个副歌。好吧，很好。
No, it wasn't good. It was an awful. It sticks with you though. That's an important thing. And I read that you used to like Kenny Rogers, right? Oh, love them. Love them. Yeah. And I toured with Kenny Rogers. Did you? We have to fit this story into every podcast we do. Yeah, go ahead.
不，那不好。那太糟糕了。但它确实留在了你心里。那是一件重要的事。而且我读到你过去喜欢Kenny Rogers，对吧？哦，爱他。爱他。是啊，我和Kenny Rogers一起巡演过。你真的吗？我们必须把这个故事放进我们做的每一个播客里。是啊，继续。
I bet you there's a Christmas theme to it. I think. I'm going to tell you, Elf. I played an elf in the Kenny Rogers Christmas tour in 1994. Yeah. That is awesome. 1995 maybe. No, 1995. And we got, we smoked pot every single show and we played elves and we had to like set up the, the, the scenery for the Christmas section of the, of the show. And how'd you guys get around? I know.
我敢打赌里面有一个圣诞主题。我想。我要告诉你，精灵。我在1994年的Kenny Rogers圣诞巡演中扮演了一个精灵。是啊。那太棒了。1995年也许。不，1995年。而且我们，我们每一场演出都抽大麻，我们扮演精灵，我们不得不像设置，设置圣诞节部分的场景，演出的。你们是怎么到处走的？我知道。
I know tour bus. Come on. We just took a sled. No. But I remember being on the tour, like I, I never in my life, I never understood the concept of enjoying, like when people say enjoy being on the road, I didn't really enjoy sleeping on the bus with 15 other guys who were the best and the most awesome guys, but just like the bathrooms and the farting and the singing until three in the morning. And I was like, guys, I try to, we have a show tomorrow. Doesn't that everybody?
我知道巡演巴士。得了吧。我们只是坐了雪橇。不。但我记得在巡演中，就像我，我这辈子从来没有，我从来不理解享受，就像人们说享受在路上的感觉，我并不真的享受和另外15个家伙睡在巴士上，他们是最好和最棒的家伙，但只是像浴室和放屁，还有唱歌直到凌晨三点。而我当时就像，伙计们，我试着，我们明天有演出。那不是每个人吗？
What's going on? The squeaky elf. Guys. You know what I mean? Call on the cops on your own bandmates. I loved the people in it. I just didn't like the traveling part just because there's no home base, you know, there's, I just didn't enjoy that part. Was Kenny on a jet or was he on the bus? Always the jet.
怎么了？那个爱抱怨的精灵。伙计们。你知道我的意思吗？报警举报你自己的乐队成员。我喜欢里面的人。我只是不喜欢旅行的部分，因为没有大本营，你知道，有，我只是不喜欢那部分。Kenny是在喷气式飞机上还是在巴士上？总是喷气式飞机。
Always on the jet. He was on the jet and you were on the bus. I was like, can't we just go with Kenny? No. Yeah. Maybe if you'd rolled a joint for him every once in a while, he would have given you a ride. But Kenny's like, I don't know extra seats. That seats for my bag. That seats for my shoes. That seats for my hair.
总是坐喷气式飞机。他在喷气式飞机上，而你在巴士上。我当时就像，我们不能和Kenny一起走吗？不。是啊。也许如果你偶尔为他卷一根大麻烟，他就会让你搭便车了。但Kenny就像，我不知道额外的座位。那个座位是给我的包的。那个座位是给我的鞋子的。那个座位是给我的头发的。
That was for my joint roller. Great guy. Great, great guy. Oh, Kenny's a great guy. I'm a big fan and in his country music hall of fame induction, they asked me to sing a Lucille and it was made, you know, standing right there in front of Kenny Rogers singing Lucille was. Wow. That's so great. That's a great song. That was unbelievable.
那是给我卷烟的人的。很棒的家伙。很棒，很棒的家伙。哦，Kenny是个很棒的家伙。我是他的忠实粉丝，在他入选乡村音乐名人堂时，他们让我唱《Lucille》，而且那是，你知道，站在Kenny Rogers面前唱《Lucille》是。哇。太棒了。那是一首很棒的歌。那真是令人难以置信。
So Darius, so walk, walk me through. So you guys start hooting the blowfish. What year was that that you guys formed 86? We started January 86, January 86 was our first show. Yep. In Charleston. Now in Columbia, South Carolina at the University of South Carolina. Go Cox. Go Cox. I'll say, sure. If I had a dollar, he'll say,
所以Darius，所以走，带我走一遍。所以你们组建了Hootie and the Blowfish。你们是哪一年组建的，86年？我们1986年1月开始，1986年1月是我们的第一场演出。是啊。在查尔斯顿。现在在南卡罗来纳州哥伦比亚的南卡罗来纳大学。加油，Cox。加油，Cox。我会说，当然。如果我有一美元，他会说，
So you're you're in Columbia, South Carolina at the University of South Carolina. You start hooting the blowfish with a couple of your buddies. Yeah. You guys were in college together, I'm guessing. Yep. College together. And what was the first gig? Our first gig was a chicken wing joint. It was right across from our dorm. Come on. It was called Pappy's. Pappy was an old Marine. And if he caught you with a fake ID, he banged a big pot until everybody looked and he cut your ID up as you embarrassingly walked out.
所以你在南卡罗来纳州哥伦比亚的南卡罗来纳大学。你和你的几个哥们组建了Hootie and the Blowfish。是啊。我猜你们是在大学里认识的。是啊。大学里认识的。第一场演出是什么？我们的第一场演出是一家鸡翅店。就在我们宿舍对面。得了吧。它叫Pappy's。Pappy是一个老海军陆战队员。如果你被他抓到用假身份证，他会敲一个大锅直到每个人都看过来，然后他会在你尴尬地走出去时剪掉你的身份证。
And that was his claim. And he had just a chicken wing joint, probably 50 people maybe. And Mark and I had been playing for a while. The guitar player, we were the Wolf Brothers. And then that night we became hooting the blowfish. How did you change from Wolf Brothers to the hooting the blowfish? What was something there in the chicken joint? No, I used to give people nicknames all the time. And I sang on this show choir in college, Carolina Live. And one guy had these really big eyes. And he looked like, you know, so I started calling him Hootie. He kind of looking at me. That's called him Hootie and his best
那是他的主张。他只有一家鸡翅店，可能也就50个人吧。Mark和我已经玩了一段时间了。吉他手，我们是Wolf Brothers。然后那天晚上我们变成了Hootie and the Blowfish。你们是怎么从Wolf Brothers变成Hootie and the Blowfish的？鸡翅店里有什么东西吗？不，我过去常给人们起绰号。我在大学的合唱团Carolina Live唱歌。有一个家伙眼睛特别大。他看起来像，你知道，所以我开始叫他Hootie。他有点看着我。那叫他Hootie，他最好的
friend had these huge cheeks. Like he did the Dizzy Gillespie thing where he was a trumpet player too. So he pushed his cheeks out. So I started calling him the blowfish. And one day we were playing a show with Carolina Live and they walked into my room. I had the biggest room so I was having a party. And they walked into the room and I was like, I lied to myself and said hooting the blowfish and said, man, that's a great name for a band. I lied straight out to myself and said that. And I came home and said, Mark, we're going to name the band Hootie and the Blowfish. And he said, whatever. And the really stupid thing, y'all, I never thought people would call me Hootie and never dawned on me. That people would call me Hootie.
朋友脸颊特别大。就像他做Dizzy Gillespie那样，因为他也是个小号手。所以他把脸颊鼓起来。所以我开始叫他Blowfish。有一天我们在Carolina Live演出，他们走进我的房间。我有最大的房间，所以我正在开派对。他们走进房间，我当时就像，我对自己撒谎说Hootie and the Blowfish，然后说，伙计，那是个很棒的乐队名字。我直接对自己撒谎说了那个。我回家说，Mark，我们要把乐队命名为Hootie and the Blowfish。他说，随便。而且真正愚蠢的事情，你们，我从来没想过人们会叫我Hootie，从来没在我脑子里闪过。人们会叫我Hootie。
How stupid am I? How stupid am I? I'm an idiot. So that's crazy. So you go, so you name this band the week before just on a whim based on two dudes and another thing that you're doing, you go to this wing joint, you play a show and you guys were like, Hey, this is pretty good. You start playing more shows in Columbia. In Columbia. Yep. And then playing in Columbia went pretty quick. We got a crowd there pretty quick after a few shows, people come to see us and then we started going to other towns and hook up with other bands. You know, we played shows with Dave Matthews. We played frat houses with Dave Matthews. Wow. Yeah. I mean, it was, you know, we had
我有多蠢？我有多蠢？我是个白痴。所以那太疯狂了。所以你走，所以你在一周前仅仅因为一时兴起，基于两个家伙和你正在做的另一件事，命名了这个乐队，你去这家鸡翅店，你表演了一场演出，你们就像，嘿，这还不错。你们开始在哥伦比亚表演更多演出。在哥伦比亚。是啊。而且在哥伦比亚表演很快。我们在几场演出后很快就在那里有了观众，人们来看我们，然后我们开始去其他城镇，和其他乐队联系。你知道，我们和Dave Matthews一起表演。我们和Dave Matthews一起在兄弟会宿舍表演。哇。是啊。我的意思是，你知道，我们有
our circuit. We did the circuit in the South and we went to New York and played some clubs up there and stuff like that too. But then all of a sudden, you know, after nine years of being the biggest band in the Southeast without a record deal, we got a record deal. I guess eight years. Wow. So that's, so that's 94, whatever, something like that, early 90s. Around 93, we got signed. And what happens after you get signed? We get signed and a guy at our label tells our label president that he puts a cracked review out that Atlantic will be left out of the record business because grunge was so big and it was a mistake to put it out and we put it out and then the Southeast was doing fine. Our single was doing
我们的巡回路线。我们在南方做了巡回，我们也去纽约在一些俱乐部表演之类的。但突然之间，你知道，在作为东南部最大的乐队九年却没有唱片合约之后，我们得到了唱片合约。我想八年。哇。所以那是，所以那是94年，无论什么，类似那样，90年代初。大约93年，我们签约了。签约后发生了什么？我们签约了，我们唱片公司的一个家伙告诉我们的唱片公司总裁，他发出了一个严厉的评论，说Atlantic会被排除在唱片业务之外，因为Grunge太火了，发行它是错误的，我们发行了它，然后东南部做得很好。我们的单曲做得
good. We were selling in the Southeast, but you know, you can't, that doesn't translate to records unless you're, it's everywhere. And the story goes, it was Tuesday afternoon and the only time the station played the song, the only reason they played it is because the DJ liked the song. I think it was K-Rock in New York, but he plays Hold My Hand and Letterman's driving home after the show and he hears Hold My Hand on the radio and he pulls over at an area or something and he calls his book reading agent and says, I want hooting in the blowfish on my show this week. Wow. That's cool. And we played that Friday. No kidding. That was a Tuesday and you played Friday. Dude, we played Friday, got in a private
很好。我们在东南部卖得很好，但你知道，你不能，除非它是到处都是，否则这不会转化为唱片。故事是这样的，那是周二下午，电台播放这首歌的唯一时间，他们播放它的唯一原因是因为DJ喜欢这首歌。我想是纽约的K-Rock，但他播放了《Hold My Hand》，Letterman在演出后开车回家，他在收音机里听到了《Hold My Hand》，他停在了一个区域什么的，他打电话给他的预订代理说，我这周要Hootie and the Blowfish上我的节目。哇。那很酷。我们在周五表演了。别开玩笑了。那是周二，你们周五表演了。伙计，我们周五表演了，坐上了私人
jet to fly to Columbia because we had a show in Columbia that night. And Friday, we were a band struggling, but doing well and still making money. And by Monday, we were about to be the biggest band in the world. It took off that quick. Because of Letterman? Letterman. Wow. Do you realize there was a year period where he said the name hooting in the blowfish on his show every night. No way.
喷气式飞机飞往哥伦比亚，因为我们那天晚上在哥伦比亚有演出。周五，我们是一个挣扎但做得不错并且还在赚钱的乐队。到了周一，我们就要成为世界上最伟大的乐队了。它火得那么快。因为Letterman？Letterman。哇。你意识到有一年的时间，他在他的节目里每天晚上都说Hootie and the Blowfish这个名字吗。不会吧。
He would come back from commercial, look at the car and just go hooting and the blowfish and just go over the show. Almost a whole year. Wow. You and I have something similar that your mom raised, all of you and five kids in my family. How about you? We had six. Yeah. It's not a competition guys. You win. You win. And so it is part of that because for me, it, it growing up in Chicago,
他会从广告回来，看着镜头，然后就说Hootie and the Blowfish，然后就继续节目。几乎整整一年。哇。你和我有一些相似之处，你的妈妈抚养了你们，我家里有五个孩子。你呢？我们有六个。是啊。这不是比赛，伙计们。你们赢了。你们赢了。所以这是其中的一部分，因为对我来说，它，在芝加哥长大，
no heat, one winter, the car repossessed, the house almost going away, could barely feed ourselves, blah, blah, blah, all that stuff. It does drive me incredibly sometimes to a fault, but I don't mind to never want to go back. Yes. And so is some of your discovering your spirituality and coming into that and your drive to success is, does it come from, from any of that? Is any of that a driving force? It comes all from that.
没有暖气，一个冬天，车被收回，房子差点没了，几乎养不活自己，等等，所有那些东西。它确实有时会不可思议地驱动我，甚至到了错误的程度，但我不想再回到过去。是啊。所以你发现你的灵性并进入那个状态，以及你对成功的渴望，是，它来自其中的任何一部分吗？那是驱动力吗？它完全来自那个。
My whole work ethic and my whole having to be successful and having to go out there. And when my mom died, who do you know, both of us went from something I really wanted to something that I had to make happen because I was second to the youngest kid and, and you know, I was, you know, you basically raised by your siblings because your mom's working all the time. And just like you, you know, sometimes I know if you're going to eat and sometimes, you know, we never had air conditioning and you're living in South Carolina where it gets in the 105.
我整个职业道德和我整个必须成功，必须走出去。当我妈妈去世时，你知道，我们俩都从我真正想要的东西变成了我必须实现的东西，因为我是倒数第二个孩子，而且，你知道，你基本上是由你的兄弟姐妹抚养长大的，因为你妈妈一直在工作。就像你一样，你知道，有时我知道你是否会吃饭，有时，你知道，我们从来没有空调，你住在南卡罗来纳州，那里气温达到105度。
I say in Chicago, no air conditioning. My mom goes, well, just put a bowl of ice in front of the fan. Yeah. Cause that's safe. And by the way, it doesn't work at all. It's like blowing on you. It's like exactly. And with that, growing up that way, success for me, and it wasn't just for me. It was from my, my brothers and sisters too. You know, it was, it was for my family, my cousins. It was, it was to go out and to show my mom that all of her getting my back as a kid, when my brothers and sisters would tell me,
我在芝加哥说，没有空调。我妈妈说，好吧，只要在风扇前放一碗冰就行了。是啊。因为那是安全的。顺便说一句，它根本不起作用。它就像吹在你身上。它就像完全一样。而且有了那个，那样长大，对我来说的成功，而且不仅仅是为了我。它也是为了我的，我的兄弟姐妹。你知道，它是，它是为了我的家人，我的表亲。它是，它是为了走出去，向我妈妈展示她作为孩子时对我的所有支持，当我的兄弟姐妹告诉我，
you listen to that white boy music, why you listen to that white boy music and she'd tell him, leave him alone and he could listen to whatever he wants to listen to and kick him out of that living room. You know, to show her that those days weren't for nothing, I had to be successful. Yeah. So when you grew up, you, you only listened to country music? No, I listened to everything. I listened to rock and roll country, you know. What, to the family?
你听那些白人男孩的音乐，你为什么听那些白人男孩的音乐？她会告诉他，别管他，他想听什么就听什么，然后把他赶出客厅。你知道，为了向她证明那些日子没有白费，我必须成功。是的。所以当你长大后，你只听乡村音乐吗？不，我什么都听。我听摇滚乐、乡村音乐，你知道的。什么，对家人吗？
Oh no, no, just me. Wow. No, they listened to R&B. All we listened to when we were around as family was R&B music. But when I was in alone, you know, I used to tune in the Grand Ole Opry on Saturday night. You could get WSM, you know, late night on AM radio. And it was, you know, and my mom always had my back, well, always until she couldn't take it anymore. Like when I was, went through my kiss phase and I was playing kiss all the time.
哦不，不，只有我。哇。不，他们听的是R&B。我们一家人在一起时听的都是R&B音乐。但当我独自一人时，你知道，我过去常在周六晚上收听大奥普里音乐会。你可以在深夜的AM广播里收到WSM电台。而且，你知道，我妈妈总是支持我，嗯，一直支持到她再也受不了为止。比如当我经历我的Kiss乐队迷恋期时，我一直在放Kiss的歌。
She'd listen to Kiss the Live 2 twice and then she'd walk into the living room and go, hey, honey, let's listen to this for a minute and she'd put an Al Green record on. Yeah. Sure. Kiss phase was a bit much. So do your kids now like appreciate what you do? Like are they into, into it or are they just like, oh God? They like country music, you know, but no, I can't say they listen to my records when
她会听两遍《Kiss Alive II》，然后走进客厅说，嘿，亲爱的，让我们听一会儿这个，然后她会放上一张艾尔·格林的唱片。是的。当然。Kiss迷恋期确实有点过分了。那么你的孩子们现在欣赏你所做的事情吗？他们喜欢吗，还是他们只是觉得，哦天哪？他们喜欢乡村音乐，你知道，但我不说他们会听我的唱片，当
I put them out. They're like that. It's so wild to me. You know, I got a single coming out and my daughter, I sent it to my daughter and it's a great song. I think it's going to be one of the biggest songs I've ever had. The only thing my daughter said to me was, my 19-year-old, dad, I just don't think you should say flip flops.
我发行它们的时候。他们就是那样。这对我来说太疯狂了。你知道，我有一首单曲要发行，我把它发给了我女儿，那是一首很棒的歌。我认为它会成为我拥有过的最伟大的歌曲之一。我女儿对我说的唯一一件事，我那19岁的女儿说，爸爸，我觉得你不应该说“人字拖”。
I don't like the word flip flops. I was like, you just listened to that song and what you got out of it is the word flip flops. Flops. Let me tell you something. Sean and Jimmy Buffett uses flip flops and half his songs and they do very well. He does very well for himself. Absolutely.
我不喜欢“人字拖”这个词。我说，你刚听了那首歌，你从中得到的就只有“人字拖”这个词。人字拖。让我告诉你一件事。肖恩，吉米·巴菲特在他的半数歌曲里都用了“人字拖”，而且它们非常受欢迎。他自己也做得非常成功。绝对是。
When I die, I want to come back as Buffett. Trust me. Yeah. He's a great guy. Do you know Jimmy at all? I do. He's a great guy. He's a great dude.
我死后，我想转世成为巴菲特。相信我。是的。他是个很棒的人。你认识吉米吗？我认识。他是个很棒的人。他是个很棒的家伙。
Oh my God. Awesome. And by the way, I just want to say this to you guys for a minute further. When Sean asked me to do this podcast and my exact words were to my manager was, those three guys don't even know who I am. What are you talking about? What are you talking about? I'm a gigantic fan.
哦天哪。太棒了。顺便说一句，我只想对你们多说一点。当肖恩让我做这个播客时，我对我的经纪人说的原话是，那三个家伙甚至不知道我是谁。你在说什么？你在说什么？我是个超级粉丝。
I literally had all of them. I'm such a major fan of you guys and I was like, man, this is the greatest thing anybody has ever asked me to do. I'm so honored that you're here, man. You have no idea. Thank you. You have no idea. Thank you.
我真的拥有他们所有的作品。我是你们的忠实粉丝，我当时想，伙计，这是任何人要求我做的最伟大的事情。我很荣幸你能来，伙计。你根本不知道。谢谢。你根本不知道。谢谢。
I truly, truly, I'm not making that up. I used to sing to your songs all the time in the car, the CDs. Yeah. Put them in the little slot, play the CD and try to sound like you so badly. It was so embarrassing. I'm sorry. What now, Sean? Do you, should I try a little bit?
我真的，真的，我不是在编造。我过去常在车里跟着你们的歌唱歌，听CD。是的。把它们放进小槽里，播放CD，然后拼命想唱得像你。太尴尬了。对不起。现在怎么了，肖恩？你，我应该试一下吗？
Yeah, here we go. Just a little bit. No, I'm not going to do it. I'm not going to do it. You have to. No, because I'm already laughing at myself. When you, when you feel it later on, you just do it totally impromptu. Right.
是的，开始吧。就一点点。不，我不做了。我不做了。你必须做。不，因为我已经在大笑我自己了。当你，当你以后有感觉时，你完全可以即兴发挥。对吧。
That's the point. There is what I always wanted to know too. What made you, what inspired you to go from hootie to solo? Why do you think you're successful at it because when so many people aren't making a crossover from genre to genre, because what would hootie be like folk pop? Yeah, you know, we were a rock band at first, but we were becoming more of a Americana band. I think, you know, you know, folky, more band, but, uh, And then what are the guys think too when you decided to do all that?
重点就在这儿。这也是我一直想知道的。是什么让你，是什么激励你从Hootie乐队转向个人发展？你为什么认为你在这方面很成功，因为很多人并没有成功地跨越流派，因为Hootie乐队算是什么？民谣流行？是的，你知道，我们起初是一个摇滚乐队，但我们正变得越来越像一个美国本土音乐乐队。我想，你知道，你知道，更民谣，更多的乐队，但是，呃，还有当你们决定做这一切时，其他人怎么想？
A lot of questions in there. Sorry. Yeah, they, uh, well, I thought he was going to tour every summer for the rest of our lives. That's just what we did. And we were touring and, uh, our drummer got remarried, actually married our guitar player's wife. And, uh, he, uh, No way.
里面有很多问题。抱歉。是的，他们，呃，好吧，我以为他会余生每年夏天都去巡演。这就是我们所做的。我们当时正在巡演，呃，我们的鼓手再婚了，实际上是娶了我们吉他手的妻子。而且，呃，他，呃，不会吧。
Yeah. Yeah. It came in, it came in the bus one day and said he didn't want to be a touring band anymore. I mean, we're on, on the road and I get called in the meeting and that's what he says. And it shocks us because that's, was I effective immediately or the end of the tour? We're in the middle of the tour. He's like, end of the tour. You know, I'll tour next year, but that's it.
是的。是的。有一天他走进大巴，说他不想再做一个巡演乐队了。我的意思是，我们在路上，我被叫去开会，他就是这么说的。这让我们很震惊，因为那是，我是立即生效还是巡演结束？我们在巡演途中。他说，巡演结束。你知道，明年我会巡演，但仅此而已。
And this was after the marriage. So it's Yoko that didn't want you guys to keep going out there. Right. Yoko said, no, no, no, no, no more. Don't quote him on that. That's not what I said at all. Jason kind of did the math myself. Yeah.
这还是在结婚之后。所以是小野洋子不想让你们继续在那儿演了。对吧。小野洋子说，不，不，不，不，别再演了。别引用他的话。那根本不是我说的。杰森，我自己算了一下。是的。
So wait. So it was the drummer that wanted out. It wasn't the guitarist saying, I won't tour with this son of a bitch anymore. Cause he married my ex-wife. No, no. I want all the dirt. Darius right now. That's, that's, you know, the drummer.
等等。所以是鼓手想退出。不是吉他手说，我再也不会和这个混蛋一起巡演了，因为他娶了我的前妻。不，不。我现在想要所有的内幕，达里厄斯。那是，那是，你知道，鼓手。
He said he wanted out. And, uh, my first thought was, I guess I'll go make my country record now. Your first thought was not, we'll get another drummer. No, I guess I'll go make my country record. We would never do that. The four of us are the band. We would never go get another drummer. Like that's not, that wasn't even an option.
他说他想退出。而且，呃，我的第一个念头是，我想我现在可以去录我的乡村唱片了。你的第一个念头不是，我们会找另一个鼓手。不，我想我现在可以去录我的乡村唱片了。我们永远不会那样做。我们四个人就是这个乐队。我们永远不会去另找一个鼓手。就像那不是，那甚至不是一个选项。
Once he's gone, that's the end of the band. Yeah. Once one guy leaves, that's the end of the band. But weren't you like scared to just be like, well, that's it. So I'm going to go make a, like the odds of you succeeding at country were probably like so low. Absolutely. I mean, and then you just broke through like a rocket. I didn't expect any success.
一旦他走了，乐队就结束了。是的。一旦一个人离开，乐队就结束了。但你当时不害怕吗，就觉得，好吧，就这样了。所以我要去录一张，就像你成功的几率可能非常低。绝对是。我的意思是，然后你就像火箭一样突破了。我没指望有什么成功。
I really didn't. Like even when I got a record deal, my whole thought was, man, I'm going to make a good enough record. So they'll let me make another record. I was looking at the picture, looking at the picture of being a black guy, being the guy coming from pop over the country music. That never works. You know, and that's just strike one and two and you go in and you think it's never going to work. But I'll be honest with you. I signed with the president of the label and he said he called 13 people the day he decided to sign me.
我真的没有。就像当我得到唱片合同时，我的全部想法是，伙计，我要录一张足够好的唱片。这样他们就会让我录下一张唱片。我当时看着那张照片，看着作为一个黑人，作为一个从流行音乐转向乡村音乐的人。那从来行不通。你知道，那是第一和第二好球，你进去的时候，你认为它永远不会成功。但我会诚实地告诉你。我和唱片公司总裁签约，他说他决定签我的那天打了13个人的电话。
13 that he thought were the taste makers of Nashville and 12 of them said it'll never work. Ever. Wow. Wow. Did you have trouble creating a band, grabbing musicians to create your recording band? No. Not at all. Everybody wanted to play.
13个他认为是纳什维尔潮流引领者的人，其中12个人说这永远行不通。永远。哇。哇。你在组建乐队、寻找乐手来创建你的录音乐队时有困难吗？没有。一点也不。每个人都想演奏。
We had auditions and people were shocked because you don't do that in Nashville. What's that? Auditions? Yeah. You don't do auditions in Nashville. You know guys can play and you pick guys and you say come play with us, you know. But everybody came to the audition and we picked our band. Oh, that's cool.
我们进行了试镜，人们感到震惊，因为你在纳什维尔不那样做。那是什么？试镜？是的。你在纳什维尔不进行试镜。你知道伙计们能演奏，你挑选伙计们，然后你说来和我们一起演奏，你知道。但每个人都来参加了试镜，我们挑选了我们的乐队。哦，那太酷了。
Yeah. And do you ever get tired of playing the hit songs because we never tire of hearing them. But do you ever get up there and like, oh, God. I'm one of those guys that when I start the opening line of letter cry, hold my hand and you hear that hit from the crowd. Yeah. Yeah. I'll play it the rest of my life.
是的。你有没有厌倦演奏那些热门歌曲，因为我们永远听不腻。但你有没有站在台上，觉得，哦，天哪。我是那种人，当我开始唱《Let Her Cry》的第一句歌词，握住我的手，你听到人群中传来的那种欢呼声。是的。是的。我会余生都演奏它。
Oh, wow. Yeah. Every night for the rest of my life. That's great. Absolutely. That's great. And here's something that you've done that's amazing. Then maybe not a lot of people know as your charitable efforts with the St. Jude's Children's Hospital.
哦，哇。是的，余生每天晚上。那太棒了。绝对是。那太棒了。还有一件你做过的了不起的事情，也许很多人不知道，就是你对圣裘德儿童医院的慈善贡献。
You raised over $2 million so far. Wow. Yeah. Which is crazy. And we'll raise like, what was it, $25 for some new headshots? Oh. It's a go fund me. I didn't raise the internet.
到目前为止，你已经筹集了超过200万美元。哇。是的。这太疯狂了。而我们会筹集像，是多少，25美元买一些新的头像照片？哦。这是一个众筹。我没有筹集互联网。
You raised a go fund me. Well, they voted on my headshots were terrible. Okay. Yeah. You should be knowing that they were terrible. Oh, sure. Otherwise you wouldn't have raised all that money. I wouldn't have raised all the money.
你筹集了一个众筹。好吧，他们投票认为我的头像照片太糟糕了。好吧。是的。你应该知道它们很糟糕。哦，当然。否则你就不会筹集到那么多钱了。我不会筹集到所有的钱。
Right. Well, you get what you pay for. Yeah. But why St. Jude's Hospital? Why, what's important about that one? Which is for obvious reasons, but why to you? Sean, why do you hit kids so much? Exactly.
对。好吧，一分钱一分货。是的。但为什么是圣裘德医院？为什么，那个医院有什么重要的？这显而易见，但对你来说为什么重要？肖恩，为什么你这么喜欢孩子？正是如此。
That's just cool. I don't have any. I don't want them. I don't want to look at them. I don't have them. Well, Darius, why St. Jude's? According to the internet, St. Jude's helps kids, terrible diseases. They got their whole lives ahead of them.
那太酷了。我没有孩子。我不想要他们。我不想看着他们。我没有他们。好吧，达里厄斯，为什么是圣裘德？根据互联网，圣裘德帮助患有可怕疾病的孩子。他们的人生才刚刚开始。
Why did you choose them? Why wouldn't you choose them? I meant to you personally, your personal connection. Well, I went to visit there. And Dirk Spantley and I went there one day. And when I started talking to the people, and I was talking to one of the doctors, and the thing that really got me was how no one has to pay anything. I mean, I know when poor folks, kids get sick and they go into hospitals,
你为什么选择他们？你为什么不选择他们？我是指对你个人而言，你的个人联系。好吧，我去那里参观过。德克·斯潘特利和我有一天去了那里。当我开始和人们交谈时，我正在和一位医生交谈，真正打动我的是没有人需要支付任何费用。我的意思是，我知道当穷人的孩子生病住进医院时，
they don't just come out of the hospital with their kid being better. They come out of the hospital with this bill that is going to be around their neck for the rest of their lives. Right. And, you know, St. Jude's, no one ever, they fly the kids in. They put the parents up. They feed the parents every day. That was amazing.
他们离开医院时，孩子并没有好转。他们离开医院时带着一笔将伴随他们余生的账单。对。而且，你知道，圣裘德，从来没有人，他们把孩子们空运过来。他们安置父母。他们每天喂养父母。那太棒了。
The price of that is crazy. And then the thing that took it over the top was when the doctor told me, if we found a cure for cancer today, we would put it on the internet tonight. Right. And I thought that's unbelievable for a hospital to do that. To put all their cures on the internet so other hospitals can just go use them. I thought that was amazing. Yeah, well, bless you.
那样的代价太疯狂了。然后最让我震撼的是医生告诉我，如果我们今天找到了癌症的治疗方法，我们今晚就会把它发布在互联网上。对。我想对于一家医院来说，这真是令人难以置信。把他们所有的治疗方法都发布在互联网上，这样其他医院就可以直接使用它们。我认为这太棒了。是的，好吧，上帝保佑你。
That's a lot of money for them. And bless you for raising that $1 million. Thank you. Amazing. Thank you. Jason just quickly Googled the word charity. Yeah. I'm saying there's a sweet charity.
这对他们来说是一大笔钱。上帝保佑你筹集了那100万美元。谢谢。太棒了。谢谢。杰森刚才快速谷歌了一下“慈善”这个词。是的。我说有一个《甜蜜慈善》。
There is, um, sweet charity. So did you just perform a bunch of songs from that musical show? Is that what Sean's talking about? Yeah. Yeah. If they could see me now. Actually, that's something you guys, if I ever do it again, I'll let you guys know, because I've done an LA before, but I, the South Eastern guy for Sinatra,
有，嗯，《甜蜜慈善》。所以你刚才表演了一堆那个音乐剧里的歌吗？这就是肖恩在说的吗？是的。是的。如果他们现在能看到我。实际上，那是你们，如果我再做一次，我会让你们知道的，因为我以前在洛杉矶做过，但我，那个为弗兰克·辛纳屈工作的东南区的人，
his name's Peter Graves. He was Sinatra's Southeast guy for like 30 years. And I do it maybe once every other year, but I do a big band show. He puts together a big band for me. And we do all like standards, Louis Prima and some not. I love that. I love that. It's fun to watch.
他的名字叫彼得·格雷夫斯。他做了大约30年的辛纳屈的东南区负责人，我大约每隔一年做一次，但我做的是大乐队演出。他为我组建了一个大乐队。我们演奏所有的标准曲目，路易斯·普里马等等。我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。看那个很有趣。
If I do it again, I will let you guys know when you come by. Yes, please. I would love to see that. It's a lot of fun. A lot of fun. And with all that you've gone through. Is Jason stuck again? No, no.
如果我再做一次，我会让你们知道，当你们过来的时候。是的，请务必告知。我很想看那个。那很有趣。很有趣。经历了这么多。杰森又卡住了吗？不，不。
I started to fantasize about my father-in-law is Paul Anka. And I started thinking he probably would jump up on stage there and do all those standards. I would beg him to jump up on stage. Oh yeah. I think this happened. You guys would be awesome. But with all that you've gone through and everything that, where you come from, where you are, the good fortune that has come over you in your whole life with your family and music.
我开始幻想我的岳父是保罗·安卡。我开始想他可能会跳上舞台，表演所有那些标准曲目。我会求他跳上舞台。哦，是的。我想这发生了。你们会很棒的。但经历了这么多，经历了所有的一切，你来自哪里，你在哪里，你一生中与家人和音乐一起获得的幸运。
What is the best advice you've ever gotten or given? The best advice I ever got. When I came to country music, Brad plays, he said to me, be yourself. And he said, don't be what you think they want you to be because they don't want you to be that. And, you know, some I probably would have done myself. But the way he said it was just, I really took it to heart. That's great. He's a good friend of ours.
你得到过或给出的最好建议是什么？我得到过的最好建议。当我来到乡村音乐界时，布拉德·佩斯利对我说，做你自己。他说，不要成为你认为他们想要你成为的样子，因为他们不想让你成为那样。而且，你知道，有些我可能自己会做。但他说话的方式，我真的铭记在心。那太棒了。他是我们的好朋友。
Oh, he's awesome. Yeah. And the best advice I give. He gave us some advice. He said, keep your day job. And we're not sure what that meant. But yeah. He said to me, find a different persona.
哦，他太棒了。是的。我给出的最好建议。他给了我们一些建议。他说，保留你的日常工作。我们不确定那是什么意思。但是是的。他对我说，找一个不同的人格。
He said, find it. That we understood. Find a completely different person and go with that. Yeah. Don't trust your instincts. He was very helpful. I love that guy. Well, you are a true rock star in life and in everything else.
他说，找到它。我们明白了。找到一个完全不同的人，然后坚持下去。是的。不要相信你的直觉。他非常有帮助。我喜欢那个家伙。好吧，你是一个真正的摇滚明星，在生活中和在其他一切方面。
So thanks for being here Darius today. Oh, no, thank you guys for having me. Thank you very, very much, buddy. And please let us know next time you come out West when this damn virus goes bye-bye. I will, man. I definitely have to hang out with you guys. That was a lot of fun. And really quick.
所以谢谢你今天来到这里，达里厄斯。哦，不，谢谢你们邀请我。非常非常感谢，伙计。下次你来西部时，请务必告诉我们，当这个该死的病毒消失的时候。我会的，伙计。我一定要和你们聚聚。那太有趣了。而且很快。
I just want to say because I was such a huge fan of hoody and because I was such a big fan of you there. I followed you over to the country scene where I don't usually roam and I'm a full on supporter and a huge fan. So thanks for inviting me over there and thank you and sharing your stories through your music, which I love. Thank you for saying that. Thank you guys.
我只想说，因为我是Hootie乐队的超级粉丝，因为我是你的超级粉丝。我跟随你进入了乡村音乐场景，我通常不去那里，但我是一个完全的支持者和超级粉丝。所以谢谢你邀请我过去，谢谢你通过你的音乐分享你的故事，我喜欢这些音乐。谢谢你这么说。谢谢你们。
Great to meet you. Thanks very cool. Thanks, Darius. All right. Take care, pal. Take care. Peace. Bye, buddy.
很高兴见到你。谢谢，太酷了。谢谢，达里厄斯。好的。保重，伙计。保重。和平。再见，伙计。
God, he was great. He was great. Wasn't he? Yeah. I love his songs when an artist can achieve the, when their songs are part of us that we know all the words, even if we don't know, we know them. I don't want to be with you. Yeah.
天哪，他太棒了。他太棒了。不是吗？是的。我喜欢他的歌，当一位艺术家能够达到，当他们的歌成为我们的一部分，我们知道所有的歌词，即使我们不知道，我们也知道它们。我不想和你在一起。是的。
You just, you. I know. Don't ruin our own. It's so rare to achieve in songwriting that level of success where people just know your songs. Right. They're just part of our unconscious that they're just always. And he's one of them.
你只是，你。我知道。别毁了我们自己的。在歌曲创作中达到那种人们只知道你的歌的成功水平是如此罕见。对。它们只是我们潜意识的一部分，它们总是存在。他是其中之一。
Permian. I know it's incredible. He's one of those huge. It's so interesting to, you know, that moment, like he talks about that week where on a Tuesday, they're nowhere. They get a phone call because Letterman heard them on the, happened to hear them on the one play on the radio. And that's nice.
二叠纪。我知道这太不可思议了。他是那些巨大的。这太有趣了，你知道，那一刻，就像他谈到的那一周，在周二，他们什么都不是。他们接到一个电话，因为莱特曼碰巧在广播里听到了他们的一首歌。那很好。
By Friday, they're on the show. And by Monday, their album is, and their lives change forever. Yeah. From that moment on. It was great to hear him say that when he starts playing one of the hits and get that kind of reception from the audience, he's, he's accepting that he's, he's, he's saying, you know, this is something that I created that is sort of always going to be there. And he doesn't see it as like a, you know, some sort of anvil around his.
到周五，他们就在节目上了。到周一，他们的专辑就，他们的生活永远改变了。是的。从那一刻起。听到他说当他开始演奏其中一首热门歌曲并从观众那里得到那种反响时，他接受了，他说，你知道，这是我创造的东西，它会一直存在。他并不把它看作是，你知道，某种挂在他身上的铁砧。
Right. Because I think one of the biggest mistakes artists make is to run from the thing that made them famous. Yes. Is to not embrace it because I did that. I made that mistake when I was younger and I was like, I can do other things. I'm never going to do magic again. Yeah.
对。因为我认为艺术家犯的最大错误之一就是逃避让他们成名的事情。是的。就是不去拥抱它，因为我做过。我年轻时犯过那个错误，我当时想，我可以做其他事情。我再也不会做魔术了。是的。
Well, you know what, man? Sorry. I was in that. No, but, and it's not until you realize, oh, it's, you have to be grateful. We, our fans are the reason we are, you know, we are in the business and you have to. Shawn, the magic dig was a dig at me and every day. Oh, I thought you meant, I mean, me going back to magic. No, you're revealing a different way every day.
好吧，你知道吗，伙计？抱歉。我当时在那个里。不，但是，直到你意识到，哦，它，你必须心存感激。我们，我们的粉丝是我们，你知道，我们在行业里的原因，你必须。肖恩，魔术的挖掘是对我的挖掘，每天。哦，我以为你的意思是，我是指我回到魔术。不，你每天都在以不同的方式揭示。
How much you've not watched the rest of development. Like none of you have not watched it. You've watched it with, you haven't watched it with prejudice. Let me just, let me just stop you right there. I told you guys, I've seen the rest of development, I've seen the first two episodes. Now here's the problem. Try watching it without a sneer on your face and an alcoholic beverage in your hand. It's unbelievable, Shawn.
你有多久没看《发展受阻》了。就像你们都没看。你们看的时候，你们带着偏见看。让我，让我就在这里打断你。我告诉过你们，我看过《发展受阻》，我看过前两集。现在问题来了。试着在脸上没有冷笑，手里没有酒精饮料的情况下看它。这太不可思议了，肖恩。
How many episodes have you watched? Why won't you look at something? How many episodes have you seen of Will and Grace other than the ones you were on? I've watched one. Okay, there you go. It was the one I was on. That's not true. I've watched so many episodes of Will and Grace.
你看了多少集？你为什么不看点什么？除了你参与的那几集，你看了多少集《威尔和格蕾丝》？我看过一集。好吧，给你。那是我参与的那一集。那不是真的。我看过很多集《威尔和格蕾丝》。
With the two, obviously I watched it with the, I loved Will and Grace and the guy in the bartender in Boston and you guys all worked in the bar together. Yeah. Is it New York? Everybody wants to know your name. Please don't ask me. Please don't ask me. Please don't ask me.
和那两个，显然我看了，我喜欢《威尔和格蕾丝》，还有波士顿酒吧里的那个家伙，你们都在酒吧里一起工作。是的。是纽约吗？每个人都想知道你的名字。请不要问我。请不要问我。请不要问我。
Please don't ask me. Jason, what's your favorite? I said Will and Grace. Please don't ask me. Please don't ask me. Did I say that out loud? Oh no. Please.
请不要问我。杰森，你最喜欢什么？我说的是《威尔和格蕾丝》。请不要问我。请不要问我。我大声说出来了吗？哦不。请。
I don't know how this mic is inside my brain. Listen, I love Will and Grace. I mean, who would have ever have thought to place a sitcom in a church? In New York. Will and Grace and Frankie. I love that show. It's so good. And you and Jane Fonda and everybody.
我不知道这个麦克风怎么会在我的大脑里。听着，我喜欢《威尔和格蕾丝》。我的意思是，谁会想到把情景喜剧放在教堂里？在纽约。《威尔和格蕾丝》和《格蕾丝与弗兰基》。我喜欢那个节目。太好了。还有你和简·方达以及每个人。
So the show, it's almost like they were best friends and they were perfect for each other except for he was gay. So like they couldn't be together. In a weird way, they were kind of like the perfect couple. Kind of like a modern odd couple. A modern odd couple. All right. Darius was great.
所以这个节目，几乎就像他们是最好的朋友，他们是彼此的完美伴侣，除了他是同性恋。所以他们不能在一起。以一种奇怪的方式，他们就像是完美的一对。有点像现代版的《单身公寓》。现代版的《单身公寓》。好的。达里厄斯太棒了。
What a great... We love him. So you did not know him before? Me? No, I never met him. Never met him. No, but I'm a huge fan. Yeah, of course.
多棒的……我们爱他。所以你之前不认识他？我？不，我从来没见过他。从来没见过他。不，但我是一个超级粉丝。是的，当然。
So you just reached out, just cold call. Well, I drove by his house. I had a mask on. Not like a surgical mask, like an actual Halloween mask. I had a Mike Myers from the Halloween mask on. You did not sing to him? No, I didn't. Do you feel like you can now?
所以你只是联系了他，只是冷不防地打了电话。好吧，我开车经过他家。我戴着面具。不是那种手术口罩，而是真正的万圣节面具。我戴着《万圣节》里的迈克·迈尔斯面具。你没有对他唱歌吧？不，我没有。你觉得你现在可以了吗？
Yeah. Hold my hand. Oh, God. If you closed your eyes, would you think you were listening to an album? I think somehow your grandma got a hold of your mic. Who's been dead for a long time. Thanks a lot. No, I knew that part.
是的。握住我的手。哦，天哪。如果你闭上眼睛，你会以为你在听一张专辑吗？我想不知何故你奶奶拿到了你的麦克风。谁已经死了很久了。多谢了。不，我知道那部分。
That's what I'm saying. That's how bad it was. It sounded like a dead woman in a box. It's like sitting on her chest. And that was the air that came across her larynx. You know what I mean? Woman in a box is the name of my biography. Okay.
这就是我要说的。它有多糟糕。听起来像一个盒子里的死女人。就像坐在她的胸口上。那是穿过她喉咙的空气。你知道我的意思吗？《盒子里的女人》是我传记的名字。好的。
Okay. You're making me wheeze. You're making me wheeze. Okay, guys. That was great. Talk to you later. Bye. Bye.
好的。你让我喘不过气来了。你让我喘不过气来了。好的，伙计们。那太棒了。回头聊。再见。再见。
Jesus, it's still bummed that we... Guess what? The audience is bummed about that, too. They're getting their thumb to the stop button before we get to the... That's our trademark goodbye. Bye. Bye. I thought that upset you so badly.
天哪，还是很沮丧，我们……你猜怎么着？观众对此也很沮丧。他们在我们到达……之前就把拇指按到了停止按钮上。那是我们的标志性再见。再见。再见。我以为那让你非常心烦。
You ruin every show. Ruin every show. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你毁了每一场演出。毁了每一场演出。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。